[Music]
enough is enough news submitted by lost
in time a mom who used to Jitsu on her
son has been charged with child abuse
were they practicing no was she really
trying to injure him because he was
being a little [ __ ] yep I don't think
okay I rather get jujitsu then smack it
seems more like an artistic [ __ ] but
unless it's like actual execution and
you pop the shoulder out Oh rather gets
mad I used to think like when I have
kids I want my kid to learn martial arts
not anymore you don't want them to [ __ ]
you up huh it'll be the only one I want
to be able to choke them out daddy once
I find out nothing absolutely nothing
don't worry about any of that stuff
there's a badminton racket go play this
oh shoot that's it here [ __ ] you up
wait learn Tai Chi here you're gonna be
a monkey and do martial arts code that
would feel shitty to like pay for your
kids like martial arts lessons and he
uses it on you I don't we get my kid he
goes not today get on there 1d exactly
I'm kind of like choked my kid off her
behind and he just like kicks me from
the back all right so this takes place
in Florida the Tracy she told her a 14
year old son to put away his phone
because he'd been on it for several
hours but the son said no so she's
saying that this wasn't the first time
either that ever sent her and her
husband divorced that he has not been
following rules around the house and
he's just been very disrespectful that
sounds like a 14 year old yeah I think
jujitsu moves are pretty appropriate for
that situation yeah so then one he was
being rude to her again she was just
like you know what enough is enough so
she ended up putting her son in a
submission hold
using jujitsu and then he finally let go
of the phone but this little [ __ ] called
the cops
yes with a little bit
that's a [ __ ] - you're gonna have no
friends ever the boy told police say he
never lost consciousness but he did have
red marks oh poor baby it was a joke my
dad told me all the time dude I don't
know if that's right either oh is it
I was diggin an Asian woman this whole
time why just because martial arts at
sub [ __ ] really I thought why we got
that way too
i thinkin you thought Asian cuz a child
abuse I thought why cuz of the kid
ratted on the parents exactly that's
eyesight that's like how I do it because
I thought it was second-generation the
[ __ ] snitch dude in a press agent
kids this generation called cops -
probably would do some of these Asian
kids want to be white so bad dude but if
I get to have all the white people
habits yeah [ __ ] tiger what if you do
I wonder if the Asian parents today beat
their kids cuz it's like our generation
that are having I don't think they
really do that is I don't know man even
out in Asia they changed out they're
good yeah they're pretty extreme though
i'ma try not to I by the way beating - I
don't think like we're baby there's a
couple of smacks maybe right no like
spanking maybe just sues a little too
much then yeah we use 40 no if he could
take it yeah yeah I think at 14 you can
all out brawl right because you're
liking a little adult now like you don't
know six feet tall do some some moans or
six feet are dated I stopped getting
beat at 14 it was like peak I stopped
eating beat like when I was like 28 like
a couple years ago cover here's ago my
dad still socked me when I was like 17
like he would come home to answer a
machine like he heard like I got a dish
class or whatever and since he knew that
[ __ ] his ass up then I could I would
known I would never hit her
but he'll hit me at 2:00 a.m. in the
morning he comes back home from work
punch you yeah he become his pop me in
the stomach and then in the close the
door you just run away know when you're
a teenager no yeah I remember but my
sister was a teenager she was bad as
[ __ ] my mom went getting so many crazy
fights that her bro I mean like she's my
sister wouldn't like mad I hit my mom or
anything but just get her ass whooped by
my mom for sure oh yeah
yeah same here I just went super crazy
and I'll told him I'll stab him in their
sleep well then I was like you can't do
anything
now do it if I say that to my mom like
I'm not even joking this is like not a
job I think my mom would literally have
killed me yeah I got popped in the face
pretty hard afterwards but after that it
was like done they just stopped like
crazy my mom was so crazy dude I think
she would have killed me this year to
kill herself like that's how my crazy my
mom doesn't say yeah she goes if I
literally told my mom I would stab her
she goes all right course she would so
there's my dad and if you [ __ ] crazy
for hella dramatic like they are legit
do that [ __ ] my mom stopped beating me
earlier that my dad did like my mom
stopped like maybe when I was like 10 or
11 and then my dad kept going so then
that's I think that's different cuz you
probably had your mom's to hidden you if
you did something wrong my dad would
still beat me though yeah like he but he
would beat me with like scary [ __ ] like
it would be like a lead-pipe or some
[ __ ] you had to go to it was pretty
[ __ ] violent in our house though you
know I was a big kid too so he wasn't
just gonna use his hands he had to use
something get a beautiful face he would
beat the [ __ ] out of me I never got beat
with things oh I got beat with things
all I have to hide [ __ ] like shoehorns
and you know oh did you hit with the
metal shoehorn - no I think mine was
plastic okay well yeah the metal sure
nothing gets too hard
yeah you are it was so bent up all the
[ __ ] strikes man Jorn is actually a
great ass whippin tool because it has a
slap at element to it too which is like
a monster II was no duster that [ __ ]
around the green bamboo stick had a nice
sound to it - acoustics potato yeah
[ __ ] Mortal Kombat character and [ __ ]
dude that's what I never got me get the
belt I loved about this yeah we were we
were raised like pretty normal different
ethnic tools of ass opens I couldn't
wait till I got stronger so I could
fight my dad like toe to toe I was like
one day I'm gonna get really [ __ ]
strong and almost [ __ ] that blew up you
had your dad and an ass I never got out
my
yeah winning of what day would you beat
your dad you're gonna be like why'd you
[ __ ] leave me so to stab me dude
scared I was on the phone one time and I
was like yeah if you come back we're
gonna [ __ ] kill you so then I think
after that he's like I think my son
hates me I think yeah I'm not sure I
have a hunch but I think what my brother
did too like he wanted he was almost
like gonna fistfight and they got into a
yelling match I forgot what it was about
but they're gonna go like that was my
first time I saw my brother like like
get that mad and they're about to like
throw hands with each other like usually
he'll just take it and I was like whoa
[ __ ] he's my hero man well there's me at
that point 12 years older than me
so I think 11 or 12 so he's like 24 yeah
I think I'm still trying to hit you hit
your brother at 24 so Hong Kong yeah I
think so ethnically right now when I
when you said you and your dad got into
a fight I pictured a dojo with the top
tatami mat and they went like your mom's
like you the key body we had about
transition into or I will ever to the
point my dad would be intimidated by me
I don't think I'll ever be that kind of
person your dad will probably out-crazy
you like you might not be as strong
anymore but he'll bite you he'll do
something crazy all this [ __ ] that my
dad would be mad at me for wasn't like
because I was getting into fights and
[ __ ] it was like smoking weed like
really like this lazy stoner II not an
active [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so you felt
like you kind of deserved it I mean yeah
because I was [ __ ] up a lot of my
[ __ ] like you know school and I was
ditching math school dropped out because
it's just not gang [ __ ] but being a
[ __ ] stupid little drug he yeah
that means excusable thing yeah well in
his face you're a rapper now so who won
I remember one time I relearned some
[ __ ] about the Renaissance and I was
talking to my dad about how like the
Renaissance never really happened in
Asia or like the the revolution of
thought and you know like uprisings
like how in France and all that stuff -
and then he was just like you're talking
[ __ ] about Japanese and Asia
boom any [ __ ] punch on it is yeah
you're gonna mean dude and I was like
nah we'll see that's I had to paint a
clear picture of why I had no remorse of
like wanting to [ __ ] him up because I
thought it was unwarranted so it was
like oh I didn't do that
hey dad look something school no [ __ ]
mark
stupid ass go read a book
stupid it's like those wild hits - you
know where it's coming from
she doing a fan dance like a [ __ ] wit
yeah yeah I know a lot of Asian parents
do the whole like multiplication table
ass whuppin did you ever do that like
this not like this go to the
multiplication tables normal like but
play the wrong keys and a piano you play
the wrong note on the violin anything
then you get some occasion table one
like that cool was like you had all the
answers and [ __ ] you know I mean it was
like he was reading it from there I'd be
like 42:47 be like test me without the
cheat sheet mother like your whole life
you thought your dad had tattoos on his
forearms it was just the answer she was
right funny
[Music]
[Music]